what happened this year in jacksonville
is they won their first game and then
lost their next 15. here is shot khan
the owner of the team talking about the
two vacancies the jaguars now have they
had general manager as of yesterday they
have head coach with the firing of doug
moreau
certainly we have a lot of salary cap
availability along with the draft picks
and
obviously the number one pick but what's
evaded the history of the jags
really has been a franchise quarterback
and i think what's unique
uh certainly is that we have the ability
now to make a choice and it's gonna
define the franchise moving forward
and he's absolutely right they control
the board they've got the number one
pick in the draft they tank the
old-fashioned way a multi-week effort
that no one actually noticed that's the
way you do it not in a prime time game
in week 17 but i digress doug marone is
out i think that doug marone is out
because they think they know who they're
gonna get the fact that urban meyer
frankly has been talking to way too many
people about the belief held by him and
if he's wrong the jaguars had better say
something and the fact that they haven't
said anything tends to cement the notion
that what urban meyer is talking to
people about is accurate he thinks he's
getting that job if he wants it the
question is does he want it i heard
yesterday he's looking for 12 million a
year which really isn't all that crazy
in light of what the market currently is
for coaches right
and and he just has to decide that he's
willing to risk and i think this is what
it comes down to
are you willing to risk your legacy
as a great college coach
to roll the dice at the next level
given that it's even harder at the next
level to compete consistently to win
consistently to control and to dominate
consistency consistently like he did at
florida and ohio state nick saban found
that out the hard way and it may be that
urban meyer
isn't isn't
willing to learn from saban's example
and he has to reach out and touch that
hot thing himself to realize that yes it
is very hot yeah well all right i mean
first off you're right the 12 million
dollar thing i think a lot of people
were shocked like that that that's you
know david tepper and matt rule changed
the landscape for coaching nine and a
half million dollars for a guy who never
coached in the nfl
yes everything's changed so that's that
is like if you are somewhat established
that's what you're making pete carroll
sean payton andy reid bill belichick
trust me they're making a lot more than
12 million dollars a year a lot more
okay so that that get that out of the
way i mean everything you bring up with
urban meyer you know
it's it's true first off yeah there's
questions about how i'll adjust to the
nfl one of the greatest things about
urban meyer yeah he's a great football
coach but i was recruited by him when he
was in a position coach at notre dame
he's got amazing people skills so that's
great but that's also what gave him the
great advantage at florida and ohio
state because of recruiting so you lose
that aspect in the nfl and i think the
last thing with urban meyer too that
would just scare me to a degree
is
we've seen he's got a little bit of a
shelf life he's getting up there in
years and the last two jobs he left at
florida and ohio state were because he
was stressed and tired
usually stressed and tired doesn't go
away as you get older that becomes more
so that's where i would just be a little
hesitant or i guess i question it to a
degree michael
when his name first came up as a
candidate for jobs he was linked to the
jaguars and the lions because chris
spielman the former ohio state
linebacker is now whispering into the
ear of owner sheila fordham and i found
an old monologue from chris pielman on a
podcast where he talked about the
torment that urban meyer deals with and
i just wonder if
the lions aren't in this it makes me
wonder does chris spielman truly believe
that meyer can deal with the torment
right the nfl level which is even
worse than the college level where you
can't stack the deck with a great array
of
recruits you got to deal with the salary
cap you got to deal with parity you've
got to deal with so much more stuff and
so many more great coaches than when
you're running rough shot over guys who
are never going to see an nfl game
without buying a ticket when you're
going against some of these other
college coaches so i think that may be
one of the reasons why we're only
hearing jaguars at this point for urban
meyer and that doesn't mean he's not
going to be good right but but it's nick
saban all over again isn't it and it
could be after one year of it urban
meyer says what the hell am i doing just
like nick saban did nick saban was
miserable in miami he got out after two
years it just didn't fit with his skill
set and there's a chance that the nfl
won't fit with urban meyer's skill set
either that's what would scare me that
would and you know listen i i doubt that
i do i think if urban meyer decides to
do it you know he's very smart football
man x's and o's wise he'll hire the
correct people to help his football team
out
but
it is an adjustment college football is
not the same as the nfl like you said
the grind on the coaches is a different
grind you're not like fighting and
calling all week to make sure you can
recruit and get the best players you're
fighting and calling all week to make
sure you have the advantage in one or
two plays of the football game that'll
get you over the hump to win it because
the team you're playing is every bit as
good as you or better every week that's
where the stress gets on nfl you know
head football coaches but jacksonville
there is some young talent there you
know a guy like urban meyer would be big
for that area it's sec country he's very
popular there we know that and you know
by all accounts they got trevor lawrence
coming to town and that's not a bad you
know canvas to paint with if you're
going to take over a head coaching job
my big concern about urban meyer at this
point is he wasn't able to recruit you
to notre dame that's a big negative for
me
no why didn't you go to notre dame i i
actually i i mean i loved him
at the time they were a little bit of
like just run the football and play
defense they were a little bit
prehistoric on the offensive side of the
ball and i can remember sitting at the
pregame at the spring game my
junior high school before my senior year
just going i don't want to play in this
offense this is boring so that was that
was the end of that sorry sorry notre
dame
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports